in the last lecture we talked about the
version of the theory of relativity that
einstein put forth in 1905.
this theory which is now known as the
special theory of relativity
describes how lengths in space and
durations of time
are different to observers moving at
different speeds
in different frames of reference
and although special relativity predicts
many observed phenomena correctly
this theory is also incomplete and even
einstein himself was aware
that it was incomplete from early on for
one thing
special relativity can only be applied
to objects that are moving at a constant
rate of speed
in this sense special relativity is like
a theory for your car
that describes how it moves and behaves
with its cruise control on
but that doesn't know anything about the
brake pedal or the accelerator
and secondly in the theory of gravity
that existed at the time the newtonian
theory of gravity
gravity's attraction works
instantaneously
pulling bodies together across great
distances in space
without any time delay but according to
special relativity nothing can move
faster than the speed of light
this made it hard to reconcile special
relativity with this aspect
of newtonian gravity so in at least two
different ways
einstein's theory of special relativity
left us with important and unanswered
questions
shortly after publishing his special
theory of relativity einstein began to
work toward creating
an even more complete and far-reaching
theory of space and time
it took him another decade but
eventually einstein came up with an
expanded
and complete general form of his theory
this theory the general theory of
relativity
was not only a theory of space and time
but
also provided us with a deeper and more
powerful way
to think about the phenomenon we call
gravity
in around 1907 einstein had his first
important conceptual breakthrough that
would put him on the road to general
relativity thinking
about how he might be able to
incorporate acceleration and gravity
into his theory he came up with
something we now call
the equivalence principle
to understand this concept imagine that
you're in an impenetrable chamber
you can't hear see or otherwise know
anything about what's going on
outside of the chamber toward one side
of the chamber
you feel a force this force feels just
like gravity does it pulls you toward
one side of the chamber
and it allows you to walk normally along
what feels like the bottom of the
chamber
but is this really the force of gravity
instead what feels like gravity to you
might be the consequence of the chamber
being accelerated
when you're in an elevator that's
speeding up or accelerating you feel a
downward force
that makes you feel slightly heavier
than normal and when the elevator is
slowing down
you feel an upward force making you
slightly lighter
the fact is that the force of gravity
feels exactly the same
as the effects of acceleration so to
someone sealed in the chamber there's no
way to know
whether the force that they're
experiencing is in fact gravity
or is instead the consequence of the
chamber being accelerated
this is the essence of einstein's
equivalence principle and although we
didn't
know exactly where it would lead him yet
this insight made einstein begin to
speculate
that acceleration and gravity might be
very deeply interconnected
to better appreciate the nature of the
equivalence principle consider what we
mean when we use the word mass
in newtonian physics there are two very
different kinds of quantities
that we sometimes call mass
the first of these is the kind of mass
that resists
acceleration we call this inertial mass
something with a lot of inertial mass
like a boulder for example
requires a lot more force to move than
something with much
less inertial mass like a baseball the
second kind of mass
is the mass that gravity acts upon we
call this kind of mass gravitational
mass
the weird and surprising thing is that
the inertial mass of an object
always seems to be exactly equal to its
gravitational mass
as far as we know there are no objects
in our universe with more inertial mass
than gravitational mass or vice versa
for some reason unknown before einstein
the inertial mass and gravitational mass
of an object were always exactly the
same
but einstein's equivalence principle
provided us with an insight
as to why this was the case after all
einstein was beginning to think that the
force of gravity was really just
acceleration in some sense
and if this was the case then it might
not be all that surprising
that gravitational mass was really just
the same thing as inertial mass
well before einstein constructed his
theory of general relativity
he recognized a particularly important
consequence of the equivalence principle
beams of light should be subtly
deflected or bent
by the force of gravity a few years
later in 1911
he published an article that pointed
this out
he entitled this article on the
influence of gravity on the propagation
of light
and in it einstein presented a
calculation showing that a ray of light
passing by the sun
should be deflected by about 0.83 arc
seconds
or about 1 4 000 of a degree a very
subtle effect indeed but one that could
in principle
be tested but under normal circumstances
any light that was deflected by the sun
would be lost in the much brighter sea
of ordinary sunlight
in order to see or detect the deflected
beam of light as it skims past the sun
the light of the sun would have to be
blocked out
so in order for such a measurement to
succeed it would have to be made under
the conditions of a nearly perfect solar
eclipse
the next solar eclipse was predicted to
take place three years later
in 1914 at that time einstein hoped that
his prediction
in the equivalence principle along with
it would be proven correct
in many applications beams of light had
long been used as the very definition
of a straight line if the sun's gravity
could bend the trajectory of a ray of
light
then at least in some sense gravity
could change the geometry
of space
with this insight einstein began to
recognize the deep
connection that exists between what we
call gravity and the geometry of space
and time but even einstein was not yet
any position to really understand this
connection
in order to build the theory he was
beginning to imagine einstein would have
to dig much deeper into the mathematics
of geometry deeper than any physicist
had ever gone before
in high school you probably took a
geometry class and in that class you're
almost certainly taught a system of
geometry
that's called euclidean geometry your
teacher might not have told you that
they were teaching you euclidean
geometry but they were
until einstein came along physics was
entirely based on euclidean geometry
to almost everyone at the time euclidean
geometry was seen as the only reasonable
way to think about space
euclidean geometry is named after the
ancient greek philosopher and
mathematician euclid
and everything about it can be derived
from five basic rules
sometimes called axioms or postulates
when you hear these postulates they seem
very self-evident
for example one of euclid's postulate
says that any two points in space
can be connected by a straight line and
another says that all right angles are
equal to each other
pretty uncontroversial right but one of
euclid's postulates his fifth postulate
turns out to be on less solid footing
this fifth postulate says
for any straight line there's exactly
one straight line
that is parallel to it that passes
through any given point in space
among other things this last postulate
can be used to show that
two parallel lines will never meet or
cross one another
in your high school geometry class
you're probably taught this postulate
as an indisputable fact after all it
seems so obvious it's hard to even
imagine that it might not be true
throughout most of history euclid's
postulates were treated as self-evident
and indisputable but in the first half
of the 19th century a few mathematicians
started to think about systems of
geometry that broke one or more of these
postulates
in particular a number of mathematicians
had managed to develop self-consistent
geometrical frameworks
that do not adhere to euclid's fifth
postulate the one about parallel lines
in these new non-euclidean geometries
two parallel lines do not necessarily
remain parallel
instead two straight lines that are
parallel to each other at one point in
space
can come together or diverge from one
another as you follow them
along their paths in these geometrical
systems it can be shown
that the three angles of a triangle
don't always add up to 180 degrees
they can add up to a larger or smaller
number and the ratio of a circle
circumference to its diameter
doesn't have to be equal to the number
pi
within these non-euclidean systems much
of what you learned in high school
geometry
turns out not to be true
but just because a mathematician can
write down a weird geometrical system
doesn't mean that it's real in any
physical sense
mathematics is certainly useful to
physicists but not all mathematical
possibilities are realized in nature
what these 19th century mathematicians
had done was to prove that logic and
reason alone don't force us to accept
euclidean geometry there are in fact
other self-consistent possibilities
whether or not those possibilities have
anything to do with our physical world
remained an open question
intrigued by these strange new systems
of geometry a handful of mathematicians
and physicists
began to consider whether they might
have anything to do with our physical
world
but despite a few intermittent shows of
interest most physicists didn't take
these exotic geometries very seriously
that is until einstein placed them at
the very heart
of the general theory of relativity but
this doesn't mean that he had a working
theory yet
he did not there was still a long way
for him to go before he
or anyone else would be able to come up
with a workable theory
that could connect the force of what we
call gravity
with the geometry of space and time
to complete his theory einstein needed
to produce an equation
or perhaps a set of equations that could
be used to relate
the distribution of matter and energy
with the geometry of space and time
these equations are known as the
gravitational field equations or
sometimes
just the field equations with the
correct
gravitational field equations one could
calculate things like how
objects should move through space under
the influence of gravity
without these equations you can't do
much at all with einstein's theory
the missing equations were essential and
einstein knew it
einstein spent much of 1912 working with
his friend and colleague marcel grossman
on precisely this problem in doing so
they found themselves taking two very
different approaches
at times einstein adopted a mostly
physical strategy
in doing so he relied primarily on his
intuition for physics
something that einstein had in spades
he thought it was important that he come
up with a set of field equations that
mimic
the newtonian equations of gravity under
certain circumstances
and that respected some basic and
long-standing physical principles like
the laws of conservation of energy and
conservation of momentum
einstein also insisted that the
equivalence principle must somehow be
manifest in these equations
at other times however einstein took a
very different and much
less physical approach in these
instances einstein focused instead on
the formal mathematics of the problem
just for the record i want to say that
this was no ordinary math problem
to incorporate gravity into a system of
non-euclidean geometry
is an incredibly difficult task and it
involves what is known as tensor
analysis
graduate students in physics departments
sometimes take a whole course on this
topic
and that course is often seen as one of
the most difficult
and let's keep in mind that in a course
like that the students are just trying
to learn the math
einstein was trying to invent it
in any case neither of these two
strategies worked out particularly well
for einstein
his physical strategy led to equations
that had some features that he liked
that had some serious mathematical
problems
in particular these equations were not
covariant which means that they couldn't
be self-consistently applied in all
frames of reference
any equations that were not covariant
couldn't be the right equations
and einstein knew it from the more
mathematical approach
einstein came up with some very elegant
and entirely covariant field equations
in fact these equations were quite
similar but yet different
from those that would ultimately appear
in the final version of einstein's
theory
but at this point in time einstein
became convinced that these equations
didn't align well enough with the
predictions of newtonian gravity
if this had been true these new field
equations would lead to erroneous
predictions for some well-measured
things
like the orbits of planets for example
we now know however that einstein was
wrong about this
this early set of field equations does
in fact mimic the newtonian predictions
in the correct limit
but einstein didn't know that at the
time einstein also objected in the
grounds of these equations don't respect
the conservation of energy or momentum
for these and other reasons einstein
jettisoned the set of field equations
considering how close they were to the
right answer this was almost certainly a
mistake
instead einstein embraced the equations
that came from his physical strategy
which were in fact much more problematic
than the ones he had decided to throw
out
so in 1913 einstein and grossman
published a paper entitled
an outline of a generalized theory of
relativity
and of a theory of gravitation
conceptually this paper contained all
the major elements that would later make
up
the general theory of relativity but in
this version many of the details were
far from correct
and importantly this version of the
theory was not covariant
and thus was not mathematically
self-consistent by calling this paper an
outline einstein himself seems to have
been acknowledging that this couldn't be
the final answer
but it still rep still represented an
important landmark in the way to
einstein's ultimate theory
for decades scientists had noticed that
the orbit of the planet mercury doesn't
precisely agree with the behavior
that is predicted by newtonian gravity
it's close
but it's not in perfect agreement more
specifically the orientation of the
ellipse
that makes up mercury's orbit rotates by
a small amount
each year this is called the precession
of the perihelion of mercury's orbit
and by einstein's time the rate of this
procession had been measured to be off
or in disagreement with the newtonian
prediction by about 43 arc seconds per
century
or about 0.01 degrees per century
some scientists had even imagined that
there might be another planet somewhere
nearby
that was gently tugging on mercury and
slightly altering its orbit
a planet that they named vulcan but
vulcan it turns out
doesn't exist we now know that mercury's
orbit doesn't agree with a newtonian
prediction
because the newtonian prediction is
slightly wrong
to make a more accurate prediction we
need einstein's theory of general
relativity
but the version of this theory that
einstein published in 1913
doesn't lead to the right answer to this
question either
instead of the correct rate of 43 arc
seconds per century
this version of einstein's theory
predicted only 18.
einstein worked out this calculation
himself and he knew that it was a
problem for his theory
as time went on einstein also became
increasingly concerned that his theory
wasn't covariant
and therefore wasn't internally
self-consistent
in early 1914 einstein wrote something
in a letter that i think does a good job
of capturing his feelings at the time
here's what he said nature shows us only
the tale of the lion
but i have no doubt that the lion
belongs with it
even if he cannot reveal himself all at
once
einstein was confident that there was in
fact a great theory out there to be
discovered
a theory that would connect the geometry
of space and time
with the force of gravity but he also
knew that he hadn't found that theory
yet
he'd seen the lion's tale but not yet
the lion
at this point in the story einstein had
spent three years searching for the
correct field equations that would
complete
his theory of gravity geometry and
acceleration
and now it was 1914 the year that the
solar eclipse i mentioned
before was predicted to take place
with this event it was thought that one
could measure the deflection of
starlight around the sun
with enough accuracy to test einstein's
notion of the equivalence principle
and to test the basis of the general
theory of relativity
with this goal in mind a group of
astronomers set out on an expedition to
crimea
where the eclipse of the sun would be
total but only a few weeks before the
eclipse
the first world war broke out and the
astronomers were captured
by the russian army i guess they must
have seemed
like likely spies to the russians but in
any case the astronomers were held as
prisoners for a matter of weeks
which was long enough to make it
impossible for them to make any
measurements of that year's solar
eclipse
einstein of course was very disappointed
by this missed opportunity
but in reality he had just dodged a
bullet einstein didn't know it at the
time but his
equations he was using were incorrect
leading him to predict the wrong amount
of deflection by the sun
the correct amount of deflection was
actually twice as large as the value
that einstein had calculated and
published
if the team of astronomers had been able
to carry out their measurement
they very likely would have shown that
einstein was wrong
discrediting him and all the work that
he had done up to that point
but of course no one could have known
this at the time
einstein did know however that the
current version of his field equations
had problems
they were still not covariant and on top
of this einstein knew that they
predicted the wrong behavior
for mercury's orbit
but despite these problems einstein
gradually became more instead of
less confident in the validity of his
incorrect result
a full decade had passed since he first
published his special theory of
relativity
and i'm sure he must have been very
frustrated and exhausted after so many
years of effort
in any case it was around this time that
einstein began to present publicly
the incorrect version of his theory in a
week-long series of lectures in june of
1915
einstein einstein presented the
incorrect version of his theory to a
group of physicists and mathematicians
at a university in germany going into
considerable detail
among those in attendance was david
hilbert one of the world's most
brilliant
mathematicians and perhaps one of the
greatest and most influential
mathematicians of all time
hilbert immediately took a great
interest in einstein's new theory
in hindsight we can see that einstein
already had
all of the most important physical
pieces of his theory correctly in place
elements like the equivalence principle
among others but einstein's math was
inconsistent
and at times incorrect
hilbert seems to have recognized this
and he began to work toward producing a
correct and complete
form of the general relativity perhaps
before einstein himself would be able to
do so
with einstein and hilbert both working
toward the same goal
the remaining months of 1915 became a
race to see he would be the first to
complete
the greatest and most celebrated theory
in the history of physics
but before einstein would be able to
make any further progress towards this
goal
he would first have to recognize the
fumbles and missteps that he had already
made
this happened gradually and by october
he had finally realized how serious the
problems were with the current version
of the theory
at long last einstein abandoned it
completely in its place einstein
returned to his earlier work
focusing on the results that he had
produced years earlier while pursuing
the more mathematical version of his
strategy
after spending weeks looking over the
notebooks that he had produced in those
earlier years
einstein began to recognize some of the
conceptual mistakes that he had made
at the time apparently there's something
to be said for looking at something with
fresh eyes
einstein gradually became convinced that
using this approach it was possible
to construct an entirely covariant form
of the field equations
exactly the thing that his theory was
missing at the time
furthermore he could see how those
equations would incorporate the
equivalence principle
and how they would match the predictions
of newtonian gravity
for things like planetary orbits there
was still an
excruciating math problem ahead of him
but for the first time
einstein saw the way forward to the
final version of his theory
over the entire month of november 1915
einstein worked
feverishly toward the goal of producing
the final correct
and totally covariant form of his field
equations
by the middle of this month he had
gotten pretty close but not yet to the
final answer
at this point however he saw how it
would be possible to correctly predict
the details of mercury's orbit
something that he had failed to do up
until that point
einstein also recognized by this time
that his old prediction for the
deflection of light had been incorrect
he now knew that it was a lucky break
that the eclipse of 1914 had never been
measured
during this time however einstein was
extremely anxious that hilbert was going
to beat him to the final answer
after spending an entire decade on this
problem the thought of hilbert getting
the credit
must have been consuming for einstein
but in mid-november einstein received a
copy of hilbert's paper
presenting his version of the field
equations
in many ways hilbert's results were
similar to einstein's own work
hilbert had in fact made many of the
same realizations einstein had recently
made
but neither hilbert nor einstein had the
correct version of the equations that
they were both looking for
at least not yet finally on november
25th
1915 einstein presented the equations
that are found in every textbook on
relativity today
by only the thinnest of margins einstein
had beaten hilbert
to the correct answer this final version
of the gravitational field equations is
entirely covariant
and completely mathematically
self-consistent they predict the orbit
of mercury
and the deflection of light entirely
correctly
and they suffer from no physical or
mathematical problems
this they describe how our universe
truly is and how it truly behaves
einstein's final equations are also
mathematically elegant
and despite being unusually hard to put
to use in practice
they're actually quite simple from a
conceptual point of view
these equations relate a set of
mathematical quantities
known as tensors some of these tensors
describe the geometry of space
while another describes how matter and
other forms of energy are distributed
throughout space
technically speaking einstein's field
equations are a set of 10 different
equations
each of these equations are related and
interconnected to the others
and to find a useful solution you
generally have to solve all 10 of these
equations
at the same time
these equations are particularly
difficult to solve because they are what
mathematicians call non-linear
which means that when you change one
input you in very
invariably end up changing a bunch of
other things at the same time
einstein himself had to use various
simplifying approximations
to make the initial predictions of his
theory
these days relativists often use
supercomputers to find approximate
but potentially very accurate solutions
to these equations
so in 1915 einstein completed and
published his general theory of
relativity
this theory is widely considered
einstein's greatest contribution to
science and perhaps the greatest
scientific accomplishment of the 20th
century
if not of all time before einstein
physicists thought of gravity simply as
a force that attracts massive objects
toward one another
and in a sense this is correct gravity
does pull us downward and toward the
earth
and gravity keeps the earth in its orbit
by pulling it toward the sun
but this view of gravity the newtonian
view
fails to recognize the greater
significance of the phenomenon we call
gravity
what einstein had discovered is that
gravity is not merely a force
but is instead the very manifestation of
the shape
or geometry of space and time
according to einstein the presence of
mass and other energy
changes the geometry of the surrounding
space and time
curving or warping it and this curving
or warping causes objects to move
through space
differently than they would have
otherwise
when an object moves through space far
away from any massive bodies
and without being pulled or pushed by
any forces
it simply moves forward in a straight
line well according to einstein
when the earth moves in its orbit around
the sun
it too is moving in a straight line the
presence of the sun
has reshaped the geometry of the solar
system bending space
and transforming the earth's trajectory
gravity isn't a force at all according
to einstein
it's geometry which is a consequence of
mass and energy
by explaining gravity in terms of
geometry einstein overturned hundreds of
years
of established physics furthermore his
theory was not only profoundly creative
and mathematically elegant
it is also right by this i mean that the
predictions of this theory agree
extremely well
with any number of observations that
have been made
to date no experiment or other test has
been found to conflict with the
predictions of general
relativity maybe one day we'll find some
circumstance under which einstein's
theory fails but nothing like that has
been found so far
in modern times scientists and engineers
have found ways to measure and test the
effects of general relativity with
incredibly high
precision for example in order for the
satellites to make up the global
positioning system to determine the
locations
on the surface of the earth with the 5
to 10 meter precision that is currently
possible
they have to keep time with an accuracy
of about 20 nanoseconds or so
but according to general relativity time
passes differently for the satellites
than it does on the surface of the earth
because of the differences in the
earth's gravity and the corresponding
curvature of space and time
without taking general relativity into
account the global positioning system
would only be accurate
within a kilometer or so the fact that
the gps satellites can determine my
location
to within a distance of only a few
meters is only possible because they
take into account
the effects of general relativity
to summarize in this lecture we talked
about einstein's greatest achievement
the general theory of relativity
although this is certainly an example of
something that einstein got very right
he did make a number of mistakes along
the way
in the next lecture we'll take a look
into one of the most interesting
predictions of the theory
something that einstein in fact got
quite wrong
the prediction that i'm talking about is
the existence of the strange objects
known as black holes
[Music]
you